hey guys quick note my brand new book
the authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment
on the back of all of this jibber-jabber
about how everyone is going to die of
the delta variant and again
let me remind you these vaccine it's
amazing
i'm like the opposite of a quote-unquote
vaccine denier i think these vaccines
are incredibly effective
in fact according to research
square.com they put together a really
cool chart showing how much a risk is
lowered from cova 19
after taking the vaccine okay basically
number one if you are below the age of
you are less likely to die of covid
unvaccinated than every other age group
in the united states vaccinated
okay so we should start with that we're
talking about like at a rate of .0001
okay 0.0001 percent of people who are
unvaccinated under the age of 30 will
die of covet
those are very very low numbers nobody
stops their life
to prevent the chance of a 0.0001
chance of dying nobody does that okay
but how effective are these vaccines
if you are at the age of 30 then your
risk
from death of covet 19 goes from point
zero zero one percent
which is one in about let's see
100 one in a thousand one ten thousand
one hundred thousand
it's about one in one hundred thousand
if you are at the age of thirty like
below the age of 35
okay it goes from that to point zero
zero zero one percent
okay if you're 35 it goes from like
point zero zero five percent
all the way down to close to zero and
now if you go and the higher you go
the more the the risk is higher at the
baseline and then the more the risk is
is reduced
on a percentage basis so if you're 55
you had a nearly 0.1 percent chance of
death
from covet 19 before vaccination and now
you're down to like a .005
chance of death from the vaccine
after post-vaccine so that means that
your risk factors have dropped by a
factor of about 20.
the vaccines are incredibly incredibly
effective but we are now supposed to
we're now told that vaccines are less
effective which is a terrible pitch for
people to get vaccine
okay so the the this has led to a sort
of box canyon for
for a lot of the members of the left on
the one hand they keep down playing the
efficacy of the vaccine
on the other hand they want to force you
to get the vaccine okay you don't you
wouldn't have to force people to get the
vaccine if you just
made clear how effective the vaccine is
you wouldn't and if people chose to get
unvaccinated and go about their daily
business
that would be their choice instead you
got this box canyon as i say
of we are going to not give you any data
the data we give you are going to be
wrong half the time
we're going the data are going to be
wrong in the direction of saying that
the vaccine is less effective
rather than more effective and also now
we have to force you to get the vaccine
this is where bill de blasio comes in
the idiot mayor of new york city here he
was explaining
that it's time to to mandate
vaccinations
we've got to shape people at this point
and say come on now
we tried voluntary you know we could not
have been more
kind and compassionate as a country free
testing
everywhere you turn incentives friendly
warm embrace the voluntary phase
is over we can keep doing those things
i'm not saying shut it down
i'm saying voluntary alone doesn't work
it's time for mandates because it's the
only way to protect our people
or you could theoretically just say
number one if you're vaccinated you're
protected and number two
you could stop lying about how the
vaccinated are the real vectors of
transmission
and the vaccinated are like they've
they've split the message and in
splitting the message
they've undermined their own trust and
not only that they've undermined
confidence in the power of the vaccine
in the first place
nancy pelosi is doing the same thing she
announced a mass mandate in the house
again now here's the thing
i believe every democrat in the house
has had the vaccine at this point
so i'm not sure exactly what she's
worried about but
this is about control at this point when
people when people don't give you the
rationale for why they are doing what
they are doing
when they won't give you the rationale
for why you must follow their rules
that means that they are authoritarian
okay this is authoritarian nonsense
here's nancy pelosi announcing
that everybody in the house is going to
mask up again everybody in that
again the entire senate i believe every
single senator in the u.s senate
is vaccinated at this point every
democrat in the house is vaccinated
i believe most of the republican house
members are vaccinated if they're not
that's their problem but here's nancy
pelosi saying
that she's going to mandate masks on the
house floor again
consistent with the newly updated
guidance from the office of the
attending fellow
physician related to the increased
threat
from the delta variant of the virus the
chair wishes to inform all members
and staff that mask once again be
required in the hall
of the house members are reminded that
under house resolution 38
the sergeant-at-arms is authorized and
directed to impose a fine
against any member acting in violation
of this policy
so they're going to find people now okay
at this point it is just about the
control so kevin mccarthy said okay our
guys aren't masking
like we're not doing that anymore we're
done so nancy pelosi called him a
because this is this is
so much of this right now is about not
convincing people
so much of this is not about getting
people vaccinated it is not about
restoring people's freedoms
it's not about giving people freedom of
choice and respecting them as individual
human beings
it is about control and othering and
treating everybody who thinks
differently than you
as a bad person the masks have become a
sign
that you are a grade a student you're
the kid who gets the gold star in class
as my friend john podhort said on the
commentary magazine podcast
for people who are wearing the mask at
this point vaccinated particularly
this is just another sign that you
adhere to the regime
that that knows best for you you you
listen to the quote unquote experts now
here's the thing if the experts don't
present you data they're not
they're not much kind of expert and if
they've shifted their position
a thousand times based on the same data
they're not super expert
are they but here's nancy pelosi saying
that anyone who won't mask up including
the vaccinated is some sort of
mask mandate speaker pelosi any response
to the backlash
for the response that's the purview of
the capital physician the official
capacity mandate from him i have nothing
to say about that except we honor it
leader mccarthy's
leader mccarthy says it's against the
science
he's such a says nancy pelosi
mccarthy responded by saying weird
because you weren't wearing a mask like
in the middle of the pandemic when
you're getting your hair
cut correct the mask is now the sign of
virtue for a lot of people
the mask is the sign of virtue you're a
better person if you wear the mask
the mask is just a tool the mask is just
a tool
that you are supposed to use in certain
circumstances in order to prevent
transmission when there's no vaccine
available
you want to encourage people to get the
vaccine the vaccination tell people that
they are on their own and they get to
make free decisions and then they can do
risk assessments
you know many people have come up to me
who are unvaccinated in the past couple
of weeks thanks to the uptick in delta
and said they are now thinking about
getting vaccinated a lot
you know why because they're afraid of
getting it because that's the way that
people assess risk
but they don't want you to assess risk
they don't want you to use individual
judgment they don't want you to make
judgment based on science they want to
tell you what to do and not tell you why
they are telling you what what to do
that's what they want and that's ugly
and it's un-american it really is
present the evidence for why you are
recommending what you're recommending
and then i'll take it seriously
otherwise shut the f
up who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like
and subscribe